praticamente ragazzi loket league e la
discoteca per nerd cioè a musica
bellissimo cioè in ombra non escono
anche più il sabato sera d'estate
contento subito le mie dita vero quello
era photoshop ma ci sono andato di un
vicino che voi non potete capire quindi
adesso ve lo spiego tranquilli allora io
dovete sapere che ho le mie capi e nel
senso che io ho persone alle quali si
racconto le mie storie e in base al
fatto se ridono o meno se piace a loro
questa storia che sta raccontando vedo
se raccontarla in un video ecco è questa
qua e una di quelle che quando la
racconto piace sempre di più come state
innanzitutto come al solito domanda
tanto per fare ti voglio le persone che
dicono tipo come stai come stai dato non
serve a niente
nessuna non gli frega di come stai netto
nei appena all'altro però sono il primo
che lo fa quindi fate bene posso allora
ragazzi vi spiego un po cosa andremo a
fare oggi vi racconto delle mie
un giorno ho scoperto di non il mio
corpo non si rigenera come quello di
wolverine era wolverine che si rigenera
buono so cosa è successo al mio dito per
poi dopo ve lo faccio vedere
per quello che ne rimane allora ero in
montagna e io vado in montagna perché mi
piace stare tranquillo col notai non c'è
nessuno ci sono le pecorelle
quindi posso andare in giro tranquillo
però anche le pecore ogni tanto mi
chiedo di self eroina montagnano ed ero
a casa non ero a casa mia era ospite a
casa di persone in the di persona nei
casini in montagna ragazzi molto spesso
sono sono tanto tanto piccole c'era
questa casa o venti metri quadri c'era
il bagno il salone era veramente grosso
della due volte il bagno quindi
veramente una casa minuscola e quindi
quando vai al cesso e cagli tutti
sentono tutto è una cosa meravigliosa
ragazzi fatevi cagare alle 9 del mattino
perché io pago il mattino che è un
piacere tutti quanti sentivano la
colonna sonora un piacere ho fatto un
sacco di amicizia così male comunque
bando alle ciance vi racconto
esattamente cosa è successo allora entrò
in bagno dovevo farmi la doccia perché
avevo camminato tutto il giorno sulle
montagne zuppo di sudore e poi tra
l'altro pubblicato anche un borbotto di
pioggia era quella volta che non perso
il telefono in mezzo alle montagne vi
ricordate quel video ragazzi due anni fa
quello lì bravo si è visto ricordato
adesso anche il periodo rimane da quel
periodo ero in baja devo farmi la doccia
mi avvicino alla vantino mi faccio la
barba prima di parlare la doccia ora so
che molti di voi quando sentiranno menta
brasiliana ma poi j
ma quale barbagia maastricht in realtà a
me la barba un po cresce poca cioè
sembra sempre con i baffetti sembra
trovarsi condomini cresce la barba come
fabio cioè non per carità non è che
fabio sia un brutto ragazze non ho
niente contro i baffetti solo che non è
il mio stile è successo questo mi sono
spogliato nudo per farla dolce
ovviamente le faccio la doccia collega
quei calzini no solo una volta è
successo mai ero ubriaco andiamo avanti
faccio per entrare in doccia però mi
accorgo che avevo un principio di
barbetta allora mi avvicino allo
specchio completamente nudo e mi accingo
a farmi la barba prima di entrare nella
nella voce dentro poi da lì sull entrato
nella doccia già ero nudo ero già pronto
però mi fa qui la sala dove metto la
mano dentro la pochette si chiama
progetto è quella roba lì
ora progetto le portano solo le ragazze
vabbè poi c'è la mia porta a porta cose
per il bagno ci infila una mano rientro
per trovare il rasoio per tagliarmi la
barba e non lo trovo e di kobe ha
definito il mio rasoio e s'è perso come
possibile lo tengo sempre di dentro non
uso mai quindi bello nuovo limpido
bijoux a letto e non lo trovo non sono
stato tanto a cercarlo con lo sguardo
senza solo col tatto nuovo trova bene
allora vedo lì che sul sul comodino del
bagno vedo che ci sono dei rasoi che non
erano miei erano dei proprietari di
quella casa era cosa ho fatto e trovare
dai lo faccio non lo faccio i foto un
rasoio noli foto rasoi in foto un rasoio
gli ho potuto ragione io che ero
combattuto se farlo o meno perché mi
sentivo un po cioè non mi va di perché
poi non mi andava neanche di chiederlo
in prestito poi e roero nudo cosa gli
chiedevo il secondo me non me
l'avrebbero dato la voce di tra gioia
ecco quindi dove gli hanno fregato
beatamente ho sbagliato un tiro
incredibile 3 è prendo questo rasoio che
non è mio
mi faccio la barba quel poco di barba
che potevo farmi nella faccio non mi
saccone anche la faccia che era ancora
un pochettino sporca di di schiuma da
barba perché tanto dovevo entrare nella
doccia cosa faccio prima di internet e
la doccia aprendo il rasoio e l'unico in
fondi simo alla mia proietta la mia la
mia custodia di oggetti da bagno la
metti il foehn dissi ma perché ho paura
che chi è
sarebbe poi entrato nel bagno la paura
che vedesse appunto che avevo pregato il
suo rasoio onde evitare questo problema
proprio rinfilato proprio in fondo alla
pochette e proprio messo la manata in
fondi simo in modo che non lo vedesse
appunto nessuno
mentre lo infilava in fondo nel fondo la
mia cosciente c'era il mio rasoio di
prima che non aveva la sicura cerasoli
anno le lame non so se avete visto 13
anna bega e allora per evitare di
tagliarsi accidentalmente c'è la
copertura del rasoio anche un pezzo di
plastica che sta sopra le lame non era
sopra il mio rasoio io metto in fondo il
rasoio del mio della persona la quale ho
fregato e senza saperlo avevo appoggiato
il dito questo lo aveva appoggiato sopra
una lama del mio rasoio ho fatto questo
movimento ragazzi ha fatto questo
trama fortissimo tavolo ha omesso rasoio
in fondo e ho tolto la mano velocissimo
non sapendo di averla sopra la lama ha
fatto bravo ok ora è la vostra reazione
sicuramente voi che state parlando video
sarà stata questa cosa che fanno tutti
tutti ok io quel momento non ho fatto ho
tirato giù il calendario però ve la
spiego bene di fisico perché vi faccio
vedere nelle movenze quale è stata la
mia reazione
pax subito mi sono aggrappato subito il
dito perché come ho fatto quando ho
sentito un dolore incredibile che non ho
fatto neanche in tempo a capire che la
stesse succedendo ho fatto proprio pack
tac che mi sono aggrappato subito il
dito perché non mi ero tagliato abbiamo
staccato un pezzo di di polpastrello in
quel preciso momento in cui non avevo la
mano sul dito ho sentito un dolore che
non mi posso spiegare però poi ho messo
subito la mano sul viso e in questa
esatta posizione non sentivo niente ma
se ti voto lorraine e nulla perché stavo
comprimendo il dito quindi il sangue non
confluiva e stavo inoltre coprendo la
ferita completamente quindi non sentivo
male per niente però ero così nudo però
ho provato un attimino ad allentare la
presa come allentava sentivo male poi
dall'altro
[Musica]
facciamo schifo cosa devo fare mi
rivesto e chiede aiuto ok marchiate v1
nudo che si deve rivestire così non
potevo staccare la io dovevo vestirmi
senza staccare la mano dal dito come fai
a vestirti se sei nudo cui in questa
notizia è difficile però sicuro è
difficile soprattutto non puoi mettere
la maglia però almeno si puoi mettere le
mutande i pantaloni promettere le
mutande i pantaloni se siete trovate
cioè mettere mutando i pantaloni da così
preva giratevi che non dovete muovere
neanche un niente del dito perché come
vi muovete si apre la ferita dovete
stare fermissimi e provare a vestirmi
gli assicuri ci ho messo il quarto d'ora
ci ho messo un quarto d'ora a mettermi
le mutande i pantaloni perché ero in
questa posizione mi sono messo mutande e
pantaloni e ho chiamato aiuto arrivate i
medici hanno fasciato il dito che tra
l'altro per facendo un casino perché
come lo toglievo per disinfettarlo
usciva vabbè la showgirl vi dico la
verità si è rimarginato molto bene oggi
non si vedeva ben fatte che non ci
arriva fino a lì a sommare se
l'immaginato molto bene forse da quasi
vede ma riesco a farvi vedere il dito
per bene porco demonio però va beh era e
tipo 4 non si vede bene perché se lo
avvicino più di un tot non mette troppo
a fuoco dal vivo quando facciamo gli
eventi ve lo faccio vedere c'è
praticamente c'è un pezzo di
polpastrello qua che non all impronta
digitale perché si è rigenerato senza
all'impronta io cercavo su google ma i
polpastrelli tagliati si rigenerano
punto di domanda
bellissimi e comunque mi hanno fasciato
tutto il dito non vi dico per togliere
la mano che casino sfasciato tutto il
litorale insomma poi avviene i servizi
generate tutto tra l'altro mentre ero in
montagna e ci aveva stupito fu gigante
fasciato il giorno dopo non ho fatto
niente sono stato confermi in casa avevo
letto come nuovo il di come faccio
qualcosa di strano mi si stacca tutto ed
è un casino cola sangue ovunque quindi
cerco di non fare cose strane no il
giorno dopo ancora sono andato in bici
mi è venuta questa bellissima idea di
andare in bici e dove dai esco in bici
ciò il dito tutto fasciato vado in giro
comprendendo la bici così questo titolo
tengo in alto tanto non mi fa niente
cerco di non fare movimenti strani sono
caduto dalla bici ho fatto un front flip
con la bici sono
per terra e stato bellissimo davidico
c'era una discesa
c'era una bocca società discesa la ruota
davanti della bici siepi io stavo
andando pnp esondando piano giuro però
la ruota davanti della bici si è
conficcata in questa buca e quindi il
retro della bici mi è caduto su di sopra
e io sono cascato per terra col dito
tutto il fasciato di sangue
ecco perché gioca del pime
quindi ragazzi questa è la mia storia di
come così ho perso il dito in data al
pastrello però era volevo fare questa
copertina senza al dito la figura più
che altro fra finale ai mie tecniche di
photoshop però bello è una storia molto
bella soprattutto quando racconti il
fatto che c'è il ditino sulla lama e fai
più grande e bellissimo del bellissimo
proprio sento ancora l'odore di sangue
bellissimo noi ragazzi ci vediamo al
prossimo video se volete sapere delle
mie disgrazie sono sempre qua non vi
preoccupate cioè mi sono piaciuto
ragazzi iscrivetevi al canale
schiacciate il tasto mi piace e noi come
sempre ci rivediamo ci vediamo al
prossimo video
sperando di non raccontare storie come
questa ma un po più da ragazzi
[Musica]